probably worth it for a lot of people on
earth to pay a thousand bucks
for the year to figure out
if they should make the jump because if
you think about why most people don't do
it they're scared
and they're scared financially
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
vaynernation how are you excited to be
in the office to do this podcast
two lovely gentlemen that i will
introduce in a second but first of all i
just want to say thank you to the
community it's been um an amazing couple
years as uh
as i've started to like hit the world
post coven though it's not fully out and
literally had four people this morning
email
caitlyn rob like just like bombarded so
i think this kind of what always happens
but nonetheless i think the world is uh
gathering itself on dealing with the
pandemic and as i get more and more
about
um you know uh super bowl this last
weekend for my friend's birthday just as
i hit the streets of the world just
completely blown away by the kindness
and admiration of the people coming up
to me and thanking me for the content
that i thank you in return and it was
very top of mind for me so i wanted to
start this podcast episode with that i
also continue on the journey this year
with interviews that are interesting to
me and i think you could tell by the
interviews i've done this year even
closer to me this is one of those
scenarios because what we're about to
talk about is something i'm very
passionate about day one the startup
we're about to talk about with the
co-founders here
is a startup that i think is attacking
a subject matter that's very near and
dear to my heart i think the world is
evolving i think
that is going to require
entrepreneurs
i think there's a lot of strengths and
weaknesses in everything government
education systems entrepreneurship has
plenty weaknesses including when it gets
super popular like it has in the last
decade and a lot of people enter it even
though they aren't meant for it and it
leads to a lot of anxiety and judgment
that is very hard on entrepreneurs and
if you're not built for that it can be
very challenging on the flip side
what entrepreneurship does more than
anything in my opinion as an entity
energy in the world
is it creates the things we need
and i think right now in this time of
transition web 2 web 3 technology
we need things
and startups to attack
the realities of people's lives and i
think college was an incredible
innovation
and but i think that
we need stuff for people and i think
when phil toronto first told me about
what you two were doing phil is my right
hand and my partner in my investing um
it really struck a chord and so with
that set up why don't you to introduce
yourselves and tell us what you guys do
thanks gary
you don't have to look in camera
what's up camera first i'm good
appreciate you having us um
andrew here for everyone listening um
co-founder of day one with my partner
cool
and and yeah day one uh
is our startup we built it uh it's about
two years old now and i kind of go back
there to say we launched day one in the
early days of the pandemic you kind of
referenced that we're just sort of
coming back to life a little bit
and it was really in the summer of 2020
when um
when we were launching day one we went
out we come from different backgrounds i
come from
startup worlds he comes from the social
impact world he was doing investing i
was building startups
but in that summer of 2020 we were
feeling what we felt like millions of
people were feeling they were you know
completely uh cut loose they're moving
out of the city they were leaving their
nine to fives or at least thinking about
it and there was just like energy of
entrepreneurship and so what we built
back then was we built the community
that we wanted ourselves right we were
all going remote we built this virtual
community that was more than just a
slack you know it was it was
intentionally built to get entrepreneurs
or entrepreneurial people right way more
than just most of the folks who joined
our community
uh would not call themselves founders at
the time they had entrepreneurial
tenancies but were executives they were
executives they were i'm looking around
these buildings like they were they were
here right now maybe they were in their
apartments in brooklyn but and they were
isolated and they wanted to do something
they had that drive they didn't know
what to do and so we gave them a room to
to come together to build these
relationships to how long have you two
known each other prior to starting the
company six months
we met in the way that entrepreneurs me
which is at one of these networking
events physically physically
yeah
um but then it was i mean this is a
great story you can probably tell a
whole bunch as you know i put a landing
page up for day one and will apply to it
literally yeah so i i'm so i always joke
that i'm a gen xer stuck in a gen z body
started out in oil and gas then did
social sector work lived in india
building ultimate frisbee leagues for
village girls
doing service work
loved the nonprofit side of things i
came back and basically set up and ran
fundraising 501c3 shops for
international girls orgs so that's where
i learned how to fundraise a lot of my
board members were vc folks i really
kind of got integrated into what's
happening and how innovation starts a
lot of the programs that i was raising
money for
was around social entrepreneurship and
people around the
world makes little to nothing right but
they're trying to innovate education and
water scarcity and all these other
things
um but then as i
want to do like every couple of years i
switched careers and so i got into
innovation about three years ago in new
york when he was still at human ventures
i went and we met and i i was kind of
our customer i have all the things on
paper that you need in terms of grit and
spike and domain expertise and just the
want but i don't have any of that formal
education on what to do how do you
validate an idea we had a really nice
conversation so you're a good dude but
you know not a good fit for what we're
looking for which was more of the
classic venture top zero zero one
percent of people that will invest in
building an idea i was in a number of
other communities and then six months
later summer of 2020 my buddy andrew i
went for 20 minutes
had a linkedin post saying hey i'm
starting this community for early stage
founders looking to have their hand held
a little bit to like walk you through
the process i apologize so you're in and
you're investing
and
summer of 2020
by the way it's been so long that i
thought this was the summer before so
this is colbert happens in march
this so you start this
this is the real question for me
curiosity you start this because you
think this could be a lead gen community
for your investing or you were ready to
live your hypothesis
you wanted to operate no longer bet on
operators exactly i was at an adventure
studio i was always the bridesmaid not
the bride right yeah i was helping all
these entrepreneurs build these
businesses
and did you have like the human belief
of like this wait a minute
these guys and gals that i'm helping
this is just you talking to yourself and
we're always hopefully actually
something i'm trying to get more people
to
be
i was about to say we're always our
biggest fan i've come to learn for the
last 15 years most people aren't their
biggest fan which is pretty much the
framework of all the content i'm trying
to make which is make everyone a bigger
fan themselves so they can be nice to
others as a byproduct but
but you
had
a moment that makes a lot of sense to me
which is why i'm jumping in
you must have been like wait a minute
this business they wouldn't even have
done that if i didn't say this in the
first meeting or that and all of a
sudden you're seeing an exit and you're
saying wait a minute even if i just said
hey let me be your co-founder i might
have made 10 million bucks instead of
having this salary where i was the core
you know that must have happened it was
it was it was even more than you're
saying the
job it was even worse it was it was the
job i had at this adventure studio was i
was the sort of right hand person um to
all these entrepreneurs coming through
it was my job to help them go from
literally a blank whiteboard to an idea
to an investable idea to you know i let
that you know they flew the coop scaled
the business but i was a conveyor about
helping people launch businesses what
was the biggest success whether you had
any impact or a ton of impact we don't
need to get into that what was the big
just i think it'd be fun for the
listeners what was the biggest success
that came through the conveyor belt um
has there been one yet tiny organics of
course so tiny organics two founders
came in i'm an investor they were they
were trying to build something in the
baby space they're trying to build
something they thought they wanted to
build they had a
kind of cool idea around a baby book
idea and we're like let's walk this back
take your passion for for moms and
parents and let's go tackle this
basically stagnant market yeah baby food
and so they're at their a they just
raised 30 million bucks or something um
so yeah you know they're on their way
they're on their way so
right so so did you yourself when covid
hit in march
like have this been sitting in your head
for 18 months and you're like this is
now the moment no i literally had the
same i think realization people had
which was like things like i was like
i'm not working at the office anymore
like i'm starting to see things with
some fresh eyes well that and i like a
good fresh eye and the thing i saw was
some overhaul situation of like there's
people knocking on the doors so you know
we built half a dozen businesses a year
that's pretty good for a studio yep we
probably turned away 500 boundaries a
year yep very very politely of course of
course
people and so what about those 495
founders right you intuitively know
and knew and probably saw
here are 17 no's that went on to do
something they do something but they're
not getting any but it was from a place
of empathy right so he's building
businesses he talks to a hundred gets to
build 16. i'm investing as an angel like
have a hundred conversations invest in
five the thing that we bonded over with
the little time that we spent together
was
the next 100 200 300 right now in the
marketplace they're just basically given
a pass yeah and they don't have a place
to go community where they can just
figure out the next building blocks to
be able to get the yes to you know to be
able to get in right there's no tangible
digital infrastructure for that
community so we wanted to build for that
community because that was the
hypothesis
that's the hypothesis
and then you know we're now like
literally almost two years into this
business
one more time because i know we're
bouncing around being empathetic to the
audience
in in most simple literal definition
form what does the business do exactly
black and white so day one
we run a fellowship it's a community but
we call it a fellowship because it's
much more intentional it's you know we
are building relationships among these
members it's a curated group
and um it's for very very early stage
entrepreneurs and and is it free no so
it's like a membership-based community
you've heard of ypo yeah you've heard of
these and if you google around those
others super curated very expensive and
you have to have made a million bucks
you have to make 15 million bucks right
day one is like that but for folks in
these office buildings right you have
that so do people apply or anybody can
pay so you apply uh leave that
not for the quality of the idea because
we know you're going to change
as much for
your ambition day one's company makes a
subjective call on humans based on its
protocol
to the best of its ability
right looking for people who want to
build but that's the truth right behind
like at some level
like i always people are always like
that's not like last night the oscars
forget about all the chaos just the core
part of the oscars like i was talking to
somebody i was like you know this they
were like huh and i was i'm not gonna go
too deep into i'm like no no that's
everything right everything is a
subjective call everything is a call
everything is a subjective call and
people act as if there's
nobody wants technology like technology
bad and then they want everything to be
technology if humans are involved it is
subjective
like when i rate wine when somebody lets
you use empathy since you brought it up
when somebody rates this
like
robert parker wine spectator when i did
my library tv it's not right it's a
subjective call
i think it's important because i have a
funny feeling a lot of people are about
to apply to day one through this podcast
and the ones that get rejected i just
want to remind it's not rejection there
was humans behind whatever i have no
idea what your infrastructure is on this
but they made a subjective call to the
best of their ability yeah we focus on
eq the idea is like giving people a
place that are pre-momentum pre-revenue
pre-everything to still have that same
level of support so so keep going it's
you you apply you get approved
what happens next so we onboard folks in
cohorts right there's a lot of parallel
to a university although i think that's
where we're really we're going to
disrupt that right like the four-year
college the two-year mba
but you join uh you have a cohort you
have a class
we do things to get you embedded and
integrated um it's virtual and so you
know we can't just throw you into a zoom
room right there's there's a lot of
intentionality to make the community
tight
but then we
let the power of the community go right
we're facilitating connections but
you're building you're working on your
ideas your business you're collaborating
you're finding people work racing with
skids and helping people connect so
there's some tech
community and education infrastructure
that you guys are human being on top of
as curators to push it along the way
yeah i mean and how much does it cost
it's 9.99 a year right now
it's probably the best price thousand
bucks yeah thousand dollars a year we um
i mean i'm an educator um from prior
life or who has a background in
education we think all day about how do
you
is it structured fluidly or is there
marking periods
there's literally a mix right there's
there's both the timeline that's fluid
choose your own adventure meet the
people you want to meet come to the
sessions and the workshops you want to
come to and then there's other structure
where if you so both are about to
fundraise come to our fundraiser if
you're about to
you know so it's a fun rate sprint
inclusive of the 9.99 a year so
everything's inclusive it's like it's
like going to college where you pay 50
grand a year
i've heard
so we're trying to make it as simple as
possible um you know how's it going
two years in we've had about 250 fellows
come through our doors you know early
days it was awesome to see like a year
and a year and a half in fellows pivot
and launch new products fellows raise
money fellows you know team up um build
business this together
very diverse very global you know
probably 20 countries represented is the
hypothesis
um
based on
taking executive and helping her or him
figure out
themselves to decide if they want to be
an entrepreneur have you already
or is it i've decided i want to be an
entrepreneur or is it both
there is about there's an exploring
build track that we that's our biggest
bifurcation right so because i think the
explore part is a big business
if i think about it from a business man
lens
is it worth if you guys get great at it
you might say you're great at it now and
i'm sure it's better than just me
sitting and pondering in my own head
it's
always um your friends and family can't
relate to what you're trying to build
all your corporate friends can't right
all of your colleagues yeah everybody
around you is on defense you don't have
a community that you can actually
talk to people about talking to your
customer talk to 100 people it could be
the customer learn from them these are
all basic things that kind of those of
us that have done it get it but three
years ago i had no clue i was completely
lost i'm like how do you most people
build a product then they go out and try
to find an audience we tell people
flip that find the audience first then
understand what you're building you'll
save yourself a whole bunch of headache
yeah the opportunity cost
of of getting it wrong is so much higher
than whether it's the time investment
the money investment
we talk all the time about
making asymmetric upside bets and
entrepreneurship is that right the the
cost of doing an entrepreneurial move is
literally 1x the time and the money you
put into it but the upside can be
infinite right and for all these folks
who have time the the problem is
that's the logical
part of it
the
emotional part of it is the reason
nobody does it is they don't want to
lose in front of others
one of the metaphors that we use for day
one it's literally like one of our intro
slides is is a crossfit gym right in a
crossfit gym i'm actually literally i
almost never don't think i've ever been
in one but i hear the stories i get that
it's like
there's this like you start to get like
towards the top of your reps there are
people cheering you on right like if you
fail if your form is bad people are
helping you correct but it's
more than a safe space it's like
encouraging to go past your boundaries
people celebrate everybody else's
personal best regardless whether it's a
hundred pull-ups or six pull-ups
everyone's cheering the sixth person on
as much as they are a hundred which is
really what entrepreneurship is yeah i
mean i think as somebody who
was
born to the great fortune of having a
mother who cheerleaded all my
entrepreneurial ventures
parents don't do that
most parents put
school on the pedestal thus
subconsciously training their child to
conform to
the system
i mean the amount of entrepreneurial
parents
parents of emerging entrepreneurs that i
get emails from
because i'm so aggressive with my
anti-college
you know um content that have helped
them
is really powerful and and i'm not
anti-college for everyone i'm
anti-non-self-awareness
right so our journey this is probably a
good segue so i hear all this i get into
it
and then i don't know if we're ready to
really tell the whole world the whole
thing but the one of the things that
brought me to you guys was
this whole track of anti-self-awareness
back to like what i didn't pick up on
when we decided to do something formally
together
i actually think
a lot of businesses should be formed to
have a low-cost way to help you make a
decision
right like like i wonder if people would
pay
a thousand dollars a year in their
mid-20s
to find out from a source that they feel
has good intent
if they're ready for parenting
like it's a wild thought but like like i
would never do that because i'm just too
intuitive and we'll go but but i think a
lot of people would find solace
in you know going through a very i mean
look at parenting books and all that
stuff like it you know in a 360 way of
gray and black and white
it you know
i'd like to think no matter how great
that startup is that if the startup said
you're 4.2 years away from parenting
that somebody wouldn't exactly
wait 3.4 years to before but but but i
think that you know it really just
caught my attention here
in talking to you i'm like
wow that's actually very powerful
because that's what led me to you guys
from what i've been trying to solve
which is i have back to a studio i have
900 ideas this was one
rezzy was another v friends was another
and all three of those have been
remarkably successful with a small group
of people i teamed up with to go and
execute it that i really knew
that i really knew
and the only thing that's stopping me
from doing the other 39 businesses that
all would dominate
is
having a process
to have operators
what i would call ceos
or ceos with a heavy hand for me
which has led to something we're going
to be rolling out soon together yeah
right something within day one a little
sub gary vayner thing
but i don't think we're far enough along
and we'll put out that announcement at
some point
that was awesome for me because i was
going to build that business anyway my
first
thought was i'm gonna buy a hundred
acres in wisconsin
start us operating school because the
lindsay blums the kim garcia's the eight
like the people that have come through
vayner that i'm like oh i wonder in
seven you know
you know they're happening
serendipitously through vayner and the
two amazing ladies that i just met
mentioned i mentioned because their life
events didn't get and my life events
didn't give me the timing to say hey
like john and nate who did empathy with
me their life events work as a matter of
fact their life events led us to selling
the company
knowing both of them were about to get
engaged and like like i i don't think we
would have sold empathy had their life
of so life events are big
life events are big
and
i think that creating a framework to
find out if somebody's capable to be a
ceo or ceo in my world is something that
i've been obsessed with and i
appreciated your guys openness to create
another framework within day one and so
we'll we'll we'll tell you more about
that as that gets closer to vayner
community it's very close um
i'm a little bit more excited about the
fact that i think a lot of people that
are listening to my podcast
are very close to starting their own
business
and it's one thing to go through
general assembly or skillshare i mean i
saw all those companies come through
this community aspect and more
importantly a very low cost to get an
answer
excites me yeah i mean i mean i'm sorry
to interrupt last question actually
pointing question
of the 250
did any of them leave
it even though it might have not been
built for this saying oh wait i don't
want to be an entrepreneur
a couple yeah yeah i mean actually i i
was just catching up with a fellow who
she has an idea
she's very new to entrepreneurship she's
going up this learning curve
um life happened and she got a job offer
she took it she told me she's like i'm
actually using all yeah as i've learned
in this job and i was like can i write
your story
because right because now all of a
sudden same goddamn game right which is
i mean this was the point of my opinion
this is why you know i'm really hoping
this gets a lot of ideas
running through everyone who's listening
to this we need things
this goes back to my whole like why
don't we teach taxes in school like we
don't do normal [ __ ] like the fact that
to your point who's winning at vayner in
my 1800 employees the ones that have
entrepreneurial tendencies but play
within the lines
which is very powerful for an
organization
of course she's doing that she's seeing
different perspectives which add to her
repertoire which when you come back to
the you mentioned just i have to say
this like if you have a job and you jump
in and take a shot at entrepreneurship
you are so much more employable after
the fact
you've tried things how about this how
about if you go and
fish for a year
and you'll be so much more employable
because people don't understand there's
always going to be a job yeah yeah this
this we have to get this out to the
world
if you quit
and scratch and itch
stay at home fathership
fishing for a year for mental health
being an entrepreneur because you just
are curious
or anything else that i didn't mention
which is there's 77 trillion taking care
of a sick parent because you don't want
to regret when they're gone and name 77
other viable things that will be top of
mind for everybody
when you go back to get a job it will be
there
there's just jobs
what people don't like doing is taking a
step backwards
in on their track right well my friends
have a home well my friends all have
kids now well my my parents were married
at 30. well my dad made a million bucks
by the time he was 40. all these [ __ ]
things that had nothing to do with your
life yeah one of our first fellows in
the first cohort who's now the
co-founder and had a luxury brand nft
company um on his exit interview he said
something that sticks with me this day
because day one helps you slow down now
and do the important things you can
speed up later
you know talk to a customer build a
thing figure out what you want to do so
to your earlier question
yes we have had people raise money and
go to the next round and build out but
we've also had people decide that they
want to build a million two million
dollar business we've had people figure
out that they've taken the skills they
want to go back to their job and be
reinvigorated and for some people who
just kind of had this idea it's been
kept it was a hobby it was a hobby they
just realized but at least they
validated it they can speak well they
can go back to their emails
my biggest take away from this is oh
okay i know why insurance is such a big
business
it's it's selling against fear it's
giving you peace of mind
you know a flood a fire
death with life insurance
i think you're tapping into something
that is a huge category
if there's low-cost ways
to
let people go through a process of
answering
a burning question for themselves
there's a real thing yeah
and i think that's in a lot of
categories almost everyone listening to
this right this second
has a hypothesis of a business because
of how entrepreneurship has become
popular culture
not having to quit your job and raise a
million dollars which nobody knows how
to [ __ ] do
not you know not a million other like
this genre of like
human assistance
with a layer of practicality at low cost
i think is replicatable yeah i mean you
mentioned there's the skill shares the
udemies that was
1.0 of ed tech right yes education went
online yes you had like 500 years of
university you had like 15 years of like
these platforms and
you know this pandemic accelerated by
five for 10 years this next thing
community driven
uh you still learn there's still
structure but it's that beautiful mix of
like the best college campus you can
imagine right where you learn by staying
up late in the dorm
but you also learn from professors who
care about you you learn from a lecture
from somebody that you might not agree
with who comes in and talks
it's a university but for night it's not
just experts like you said it's in the
dorms it's staying up late and kind of
you get so one of the other big things
is like people come in thinking they're
just the student but over time of course
in the community
it helps that right identity it's a
mental health help like you really feel
well listen i mean the biggest argument
i get from people today
it who are super pro blind college
parents that are friends coming from a
good place they're like yeah but gary
you know ricky is gonna meet people and
mature then i'm like ricky you can go to
europe and do that you don't need to go
into 180k in the dead a lot of people
like ricky too yeah i mean look i think
yes ish right i think that's fair but
you know this even at harvard or
stanford and i'm not even talking about
gender race there's even as hard like
what's awesome about humans
is it's true snowflake life i agree with
you but like
even if it's
high low middle class whenever you go
you gravitate towards yeah you you know
i think you i think you serendipitously
run into different people's like they
might be exactly you on paper
same school same income levels same
parents it may look exactly the same and
it's gonna be completely different
yeah yeah i agree with the late night
thing i think i think a lot about 2 30
in the morning deep conversations
so many people that went through college
can immediately as i'm talking right now
think about those first couple talks
they had with who ended up becoming
their core friend group where they were
finally at a mature enough state to
speak about vulnerability or other
things like that that moment right that
moment i mean other people passionate
about the same things you're passionate
about yes i mean i'm super here for
creating getting 100 acres in wisconsin
for the uh the campus version of this
you know like why not like that i mean
for me for me
when we stumbled on each other i like
really want to build a infrastructure
to create
a way for me to judge
if i believe someone can be
my partner and you know
in a world where i will come up with the
idea
be the driving force for the fundraising
be the driving force for the demand
you know i think somebody owning five to
ten percent of that to be the core
operator is a gift i really do it's
gonna be life changing
it has been for everything i've done so
so i'm excited about that
um and building that out with you and
we'll have a lot more of that in the
future vayner nation men thank you for
being on the show thanks for having us
talk to you soon this was awesome
uh like comment subscribe yep
guys please please leave comments i mean
the likes subscribes i know what you
want drock but the comments
uh for this episode specifically would
be very interesting to me on the insight
or the seed of the idea that maybe this
podcast created thanks for being on
again guys we'll see you next time
you